[Musique]
bonsoir hélico merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france le
variant donc dû kovy 19,1 qui affole
angleterre est désormais en france en
ile-de-france même une dizaine de cars
ont été détectés doit-on sont inquiétés
bruit on doit fondre inquiété parce
qu'apparemment il est quand même un peu
plus contagieux que le virus qui
circulent et auxquels on est habitué
depuis plusieurs mois donc s'il est plus
contagieux il va se transmettre plus
facilement s'ils se transmet plus
facilement il va affecter plus de
personnes s'il infecte plus de personnes
y aura plus de cas graves
le qui rentreront réanimation donc en
fait c'est un problème de dénominateur
et si ce virus donne plus de cas il y
aura forcément plus de personnes qui
rentreront réanimation c'est vrai qu'en
angleterre on a aussi parlé du fait que
les jeunes étaient davantage ans les
enfants étaient davantage contaminées
par cette mutation du virus ça veut dire
logiquement quoi qu'on va également
devoir fermer les écoles et peut-être
confinés comme les anglais en france on
va l'écouter je pense qu'il est un peu
trop tôt pour dire ce qu'il faudra faire
le virus on sait très bien qui circule
parmi les enfants dans les écoles les
collèges les lycées
on a toujours 10 ont minimisé
l'importance de cette transmission en
milieu scolaire s'il s'avère que ce
nouveau variant circule mieux en milieu
scolaire c'est sûr qu'une des
conséquences pour être d'envisager la
fermeture des écoles mais je rappelle
que dans la plupart des pays qui ont
pris des dispositions fortes pour
empêcher cette épidémie d'évoluer une
des premières fermetures c'est de fait
c'était une des premières décisions
pardon c'était de fermer les écoles mais
c'est ce qu'ils ont fait en allemagne
par exemple
alors on dit tout et son contraire on
lit tout et son contraire sur le côté
pathogènes de cette mutation aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous pouvez nous rassurer que
ce variant finalement n'est pas plus
dangereux que entre guillemets l'ancien
virus oui je pense qu'on peut on peut
rassurer bon même s'il est encore un peu
trop tôt pour rassurer définitivement
je rappelle que ce nouveau variant a
émergé il ya même pas un mois donc il
est quand même encore un peu tôt pour se
faire une idée exacte mais en tout cas
on sait que ce virus mute limite de
façon régulière quotidienne
la sq il est un peu inhabituel c'est le
nombre de mutations qui a mais bon c'est
logique dans la vie d'un virus de muter
bon je pense qu'il faut pas s'en
inquiéter outre mesure en tout cas alors
on entende évidemment que le niveau de
la france pour le moment n'est pas au
niveau du royaume uni ni même de
l'allemagne est ce que selon vous on
peut empêcher justement cette hausse
inquiétante des contaminés dans notre
pays est ce qu'on arrivera à se
maintenir
on connaît les on connaît les recettes
pour empêcher les contaminations c'est
c'est peu testé tracé isolé je crois
qu'il faut pas oublier l'importance de
cette stratégie
c'est pas parce qu'on commence à
vacciner qu'il faut oublier les autres
composantes de la prévention du
visuel et collectives c'est-à-dire
rappelé les mesures barrières rappelé
l'importance de s'isoler quand on est
malade de se tester régulièrement de
tracer les cas positifs
je pense que c'est ça qui est important
a rappelé et puis elle vaccin qui
arrivait dans tout ça va va permettre
d'améliorer les choses
le vaccin qui arrive évidemment 516
personnes pour le moment c'est toujours
un lot chiffres officiels donnés par les
autorités même si olivier verront rôle a
affirmé qu'il y avait peut-être 2000
personnes en plus de vacciner une chose
est sûre c'est que le chiffre reste
officiel reste à 516 aujourd'hui il
faudra appliquer 33 mille personnes 33
mille personnes par jour pour maintenir
l'objectif ambitieux du gouvernement est
ce qu'on va y arriver selon vous
pourquoi autant de lenteur est ce qu on
s'y prend mal
on écoute et je crois que c'est un peu
trop tôt pour dire qu'on s'y prend mal
enfin même si effectivement ces annales
des buts et on va pas on va pas tourner
autour du pot je pense qu'il ya un
problème de disponibilité quand même des
vaccins c'est à dire que démarré pied au
plancher en vaccinant des centaines de
milliers de personnes
si vous n'avez pas le vaccin à votre
disposition c'est quand même difficile
de le faire donc je pense que c'est pour
ça que ça a démarré doucement enfin
j'ose espérer que c'est pour ça que
c'est pas pour d'autres raisons
et de toute façon il faut se vacciner
c'est impératif
c'est la seule manière de 2
à titre individuel de ne pas être
hospitalisées et de ne pas rentrer en
réanimation et à titre collectif de
mettre fin cette épidémie le plus
rapidement possible dr comme professeur
comme vous nous dites vaccin n'est pas
disponible important le ministre de la
santé nous dit que voilà il ya des
centaines de milliers de doses déjà
disponibles sur le territoire donc ça
veut dire quoi vous sont elles ces doses
de vaccin écoutez pourrait tout à fait
précis je ne sais pas où sont les doses
de vaccin je n'ai je n'ai je vous avoue
que moi je regarde ce qui arrive dans
mon service et je peux vous dire que ça
arrive on a commencé à vacciner
aujourd'hui on augmentera la capacité de
vaccination demain et on augmentera
encore après demain et c'est comme ça
que ça va se passer dans plusieurs
endroits de france et même un peu
partout en france
moi j'ai plutôt envie voir les choses
comme ça à positive on démarre peut-être
doucement mais si on accélère comme il
faut eh bien on arrivera je l'espère aux
objectifs fixés le plus rapidement
possible en sachant qu évidemment il va
falloir augmenter le rythme et la
cadence est évident effectivement parce
qu'on est on est sérieusement en retard
certains députés notamment les
républicains ont proposé un allègement
du consentement notamment est ce que
vous pensez que ça serait l'une des
pistes pour accélérer la cadence
ben oui il ya un problème avec le
consentement effectivement c'est à dire
que quand à partir du moment où on a
décidé de vacciner dans les ehpad
on a complètement oublié que dans les
ehpad y avait des personnes qui
n'avaient plus toutes leurs capacités
intellectuelles et que donc il fallait
me prendre contact avec des tuteurs pour
pouvoir obtenir le consentement et ça
n'avait pas été anticipée apparemment
donc effectivement il ya une perte de
temps mais de toute façon la vaccination
dans les ehpad n'est pas la clé de la
réussite pour pour diminuer l'importance
de
la rapidité des péniches il faut
vacciner beaucoup plus largement dans
les ehpad
pour cela on va devoir passer comme le
fait l'allemagne par des fameux
vaccinodromes qui ne vont pas forcément
réussi par par le passé on n'y coupera
pas ses grands centres de vaccination
écoutez je pense que c'est la solution
effectivement plutôt que d'éparpiller
les centres de vaccination un peu
partout en multipliant les endroits au
monde vaccine je pense qu'il vaudrait
mieux faire des grands centres de
vaccination qu'on appelle vaccinodromes
si vous voulez et dans lequel on puisse
vacciner du matin au soir
le plus de monde possible et dans les
meilleures conditions de sécurité
wissam apparaître le plus le plus adapté
à la situation
je voulais qu'on parle de la stratégie
de l'agencé européenne des médicaments
qui a un rôle extrêmement important en
ce moment ci vaccin retenu près de 2
milliards de doses précommander vaccin
moderne et classique confondues on va
les voir s'afficher sur l'écran on
s'aperçoit qu'il y a donc un seul vaccin
disponible et de valider par l' agence
européenne des médicaments pour
injection les autres sanofi on n'en
parle pas un qui a pris un retard
considérable astrazeneca également les
discussions qui vont reprendre mercredi
sur le modern as qu' il ya une
défaillance de stratégie au niveau de la
commission européenne on a mal peut être
commandé les doses on aurait dû mieux
faire on a laissé les britanniques et
les états unis
le champ libre pour se procurer
davantage de vaccins
ben il faut pas oublier quand même que
ces vaccins ont été fabriquées aux états
unis et en angleterre pour ce qui
concerne le vaccin astrazeneca donc les
premiers ce sont les premiers servis
donc c'est pas très surprenant ensuite
l'agencé européenne du médicament elle
fait son travail correctement
c'est à dire qu'elle prend le temps
d'analyser les données
des vaccins elle analysé le vaccin de
pfizer à peu près très rapidement
puisqu'elle a même donné elle a même
rendu un avis une semaine après que
l'article principal a été publié une
dizaine de jours après que l'agencé
américaine du médicament et rendu un
avis favorable
donc moi je trouve qu'ils vont assez
vite simplement ils peuvent pas aller
plus vite que la musique
et on comprend très bien on peut pas à
la fois reproché aux décideurs d'être
trop lent et leur reprocher d'être trop
rapide analyse et des dossiers
d'enregistrement de médicaments et a
fortiori de vaccin qui va être utilisé à
des millions de dhs exemplaire pour des
millions de personnes
on peut pas prendre ces décisions en
cinq minutes c'est absolument évident
comprends je comprends qu'ils prennent
leur temps en tout cas certains pays
sont allés plus vifs à 8 face donc à ces
autorisations données
c'est le cas du royaume-uni qui a fait
le pari d'une doses pour vacciner le
plus possible et le plus vite
c'est le cas également du danemark c'est
un pari médical ou un pari logistique au
choix qui peut être risqué selon vous
pour l'instant c'est trop tôt pour le
dire il faudra pouvoir comparer dans six
mois par exemple les pays qui ont choisi
cette stratégie vaccinale
en fait ils vont faire la deuxième
vaccination ils vont faire le deuxième
injection
mais simplement au lieu de la faire au
bout de trois semaines d'un mois ils
vont la faire au bout de deux trois
semaines de trois mois environ je me
rappelle que exactement les délais ils
vont la faire avec retard par rapport au
schéma qui avait été
préconiser au départ on pourra comparer
entre un schéma classique et puis un
schéma retardé pour voir le résultat à
l'arrivée la halle avantage pour eux
c'est qu'ils vont pouvoir vacciner
beaucoup plus rapidement beaucoup plus
de personnes
voilà l'inconvénient c'est qu'il faut
qu'ils aient des deuxièmes dos qui
suivent parce que s'ils n'ont pas de
deuxième dos qui suivent et bien
l'immunité va disparaître il faudra tout
recommencer à zéro
donc il faut pas se rater au niveau de
l'espace entre deux injections alors
l'une des informations du jour c'est
cette possible coopération entre la
russie et l'allemagne vladimir poutine
et angela merkel qui évoque une possible
production conjointe de vaccin ça vous
semble être une bonne nouvelle
écoutez oui évidemment que c'est une
bonne nouvelle tout ce qui peut
permettre de de produire plus rapidement
et de vacciner le plus rapidement
possible est évidemment une bonne
nouvelle ça on ne peut que s'en réjouir
après je ne sais pas si les allemands
vont fabriquer le vaccin rue soucy les
russes ont fabriqué un vaccin allemand
je sais pas vraiment dans quel sens ça
marche
je pense que c'est plutôt les allemands
qui vont je sais pas je ne sais pas dans
quel sens ça marche mais je sais que les
russes ont aussi prévu de de travail et
que les indiens donc oui c'est bien
qu'ils aient une cette coopération
internationale qui se passe pour moi je
trouve ça super alors ma dernière
question professeur en parle en ce
moment que des vaccins quasiment et plus
trop d des médicaments est ce que il ya
encore de l'espoir dans ce domaine alors
effectivement vous avez raison de poser
cette question de la même que manière
que je trouvais que le vaccin occulte un
peu les autres aspects de la prévention
notamment testé tracé isolé je trouve
qu'effectivement le vaccin au culte
aussi
la recherche des médicaments efficaces
contre le virus
mais il faut savoir que c'est pas par
hasard c'est parce que à ce stade du
développement malheureusement on n'a pas
de médicaments qui émerge comme
antiviral efficace ou comme médicaments
qui permettent de faire un progrès
définitif en manière de prise en charge
des malades et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
vraiment insisté sur l'importance de la
vaccination et l'importance de la
prévention
parce qu'actuellement on stagne en ce
qui concerne l'aspect curatif et ça pose
d'énormes problèmes notamment non
seulement en termes de mortalité mais
aussi en terme de durée
d'hospitalisation d'embouteillage des
services de spitalier classique et de
réanimation
merci beaucoup professeur eric holmes
chef du service des maladies
infectieuses de la pitié salpêtrière à
paris merci d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france